[Applause]
all right guys yo
tragic news man uh dmx
uh as we're recording this right now is
still in uh i guess intensive
care apparently he's in a vegetative
state oh no [ __ ] yeah
oh no yeah it's not looking good this
sucks dude so it might be
it might be over for for x might be holy
[ __ ] now when i heard this i didn't know
exactly what it meant because like i
grew up without dmx i knew the songs and
it was like 20
dmx was famous before he was born i
think yeah i saw videos of him
performing on stage with like thousands
of people oh what stock
yeah yeah yeah i was like oh this is
sick nah he was a [ __ ] dog he was
what is it he's one of the goats
what is the connection like who was he
today is there anyone there's nothing
like
like that like that angst and i thought
it was white angst but it was kind of
angst everybody
like there's certain nirvana songs you
play i don't care what communities
listen to it they're going to [ __ ]
rock out to it
because they tapped into like this like
anger this and
x [ __ ] did that man like there were
certain ex songs that like
you're you're the whitest white boy
rocker
goth dude if you start x going gave
i'm a brown hindu kid from the suburbs
when he
prayed to his god who i assume is jesus
i felt that [ __ ]
yeah that moved me i was like this is
the [ __ ] god yet man
there was not there's not a lot of
artists like him especially not in
rapper what was the album it's dark
it's dark and hell's hot [ __ ] i listened
to that to this day
to this day rough riders anthem grew up
on x
yeah yeah a lot like i was very
near us like like his hobby was
radio-controlled cars like this
just big kid just doing that and anyone
that came by like
high school just you just hang out with
us and just uh
i think what x had and similar to how uh
jelly
just like super authentic yeah yeah yeah
yeah believe
everything 100 and x didn't hold
anything back like yeah he put it all in
his lyrics and i think that's one of
those things that
like you fall in love with a person like
that yeah he was so attached to the
material
you believed the material coming from
him i mean that
were you laughing i mean no he just had
wild lyrics and that's why i know people
love him because
they would play him at the gym i go to
and it's just crazy and there's no
there's mad gay dudes in the gym and
they still going through it and they're
like yo this is fire and he's just going
off like i don't mess with homo thugs or
whatever yeah no love to hold on
give him love gay dudes in the gym are
like let's go i love this song yeah
they don't like homo thugs either bro
gay's like some fancy ass gays
no ratchet ass homo thug yeah i feel
safe he's a chick-fil-a rap
he oh my god oh my god
hold on that's true he's a chick-fil-a
rap
why is that everybody likes him no
matter what some people accuse them
being homophobic but they still listen
to me they don't care
we don't care also very religious
exactly also
yeah chick-fil-a wrap i think you just
called the black person fried chicken
but we'll look past it bro
it's okay i think that the metaphor was
so good we're gonna look right past
it because i was waiting for that but if
i'm like wait what he did to it a black
person a piece of fried chicken
that's how not raised i am i didn't even
know that was the connection it was
under your skin
[Laughter]
it was under your skin it was underneath
your skin
do you think if we lopped off those
heavies from today
and skinned them we could have some
toro nobody got it nobody got it oh
that's that's the good
that's a good tuna bro that's like the
the good
fatty tuna oh i didn't know yeah you
know
no i didn't we poor dog we have one too
many heavy
jokes man god damn i always do this
you did an a toro joe bro i didn't know
doral jones yo you know you're digging
deep when you ask
oh toro [ __ ] god that's how you know man
you're blowing up let me just keep going
further into it
it's not even gonna be any more thorough
left because [ __ ]
see spiricy man they're fishing the
oceans too much you fishing right now
cast a wider network damn it
oh there's a culling of the dolphins and
this japanese city
i got faith i'll let you keep going
[Music]
did you just look at miles to mark the
time
okay no uh save me somewhere with an
edit okay
uh but leave enough of the bomb in
because it's kind of funny
um what were we talking about dmx oh
yeah so
in all seriousness with dmx this [ __ ] is
super tragic um if you're a fan you kind
of knew
like i didn't want to be phony and be
like oh i couldn't believe this happened
if you're a fan you kind of you knew it
was coming but it still [ __ ] sucks
i don't understand those people who like
turning it around though say what i
thought he turned it around because like
in the last verses
like he looked he was clean he was good
i think he was
yeah man and that i hate to say that and
i remember we talked about that it was
like
sad to watch like snoop he's next to
snoop and snoop for all the weed he
smoked that [ __ ] was
sharp i remember at the end when they
were just freestyling oh yeah and snoop
could still just go and
x was like struggling and i've seen
videos of x freestyle and he could go
back in the day
and it was just like ah it's just not
quite there anymore and it just didn't
look
he put on a lot of weight and it was
just like [ __ ] dude
i mean if he can pull out and turn
around amazing that's the greatest but
just
you just kind of and he's the guy that's
like tricky thing though where like
you know a lot of people are bringing
this up like you know
yeah but we saw this coming his
lifestyle is bad whatever
it doesn't make it any less sad it's
just a weird point to make i
i did bring it up because i felt like
i'd be hypocritical being like
oh man i can't believe it when i would
keep it a buck with anybody else who
died but nobody's
saying they can't believe it they're
just going it's sad no one says that
when someone's grandma dies yeah
yeah like i can't believe that it's like
oh shocker your grandma was 90.
yeah it just seems like a way to like
dismiss
your feelings about that person dying
and it's like you
are sad that someone died because you
liked what they did
or you like who they are right it has
nothing to do with whether they were
ready to die or weren't
ready to die right so it's like i don't
know it's just a weird take i've seen
some of those not saying you made that
i don't think you made that take but
like i've seen some people make it on
on uh on twitter and such and it's just
like thanks
good hey good job the crackhead died
you're not
surprised bravo yeah we love the
crackheads music
we love the crackheads interviews you
know it's crazy it wasn't even about the
crack
necessarily to me that he was a
crackhead what i was i'm saying like
he felt like a guy who was like hey i
just take on the pain of the world and
that's just what it is and like a weird
like
yeah i don't know how to ward it well
but that's kind of just what he felt
like look god i'll just take all the
[ __ ]
that you just put that on me oh and i
they even i think i saw like a behind
the music one of his friends said that
about him
like that's just the guy that just takes
on pain and like you just kind of knew
it was going to meet an end that wasn't
the best but like that's why it's it
still sucks it's just [ __ ] dude yeah
he was different man i don't know in
terms of rappers i grew up listening to
there was nobody like him and i haven't
seen anybody since
i'm not as into rap as i used to be but
i just don't see that this
is a different guy
yeah there was i guess some medical
misinformation that was put out
yeah his lawyer said he was misinformed
yes people said
he's off of intensive care he's out of
intensive care
i heard it was getting better yeah he
was getting better and now it looks like
that was [ __ ]
which is such a shame because you know
all these people get their hopes up you
know it's crazy too
he put out is dark in hell's hot and
then what was the second one flesh in my
flesh and butt on my bud
11 months apart two albums full albums
both slapped
crazy and then he had the the x's coming
or whatever like and then there was
actually
and then there was x yeah great
depression all of them debuted number
one like five albums in a row or some
[ __ ] like that i mean it must be
tough like he's had the drug problems
then he got sentenced to
jail he came out a year like beginning
of 2019 so he has that year and then
covet happens and then
obviously we know that that's been
terrible for anyone from drug addicts
that's true depression yeah he's
admitted that he's bipolar
admitted that he's a crackhead it's like
so just add that weight to it
like how much tougher it must have been
that's a good point like
yeah we haven't seen just yet
the psychological effects of covid like
they've been happening but we haven't
been paying any attention to them
yeah but as we start to get back out
you're going to see
human beings interacting way more and
the effects of the
the psychological i guess mistreatment
that people have experienced
over the past year is going gonna show
you know what i mean like that psychosis
that you slowly
unraveled into is gonna expose itself
when you now have to re-enter society
yeah
you now have to go to work you have to
be around people yeah it's gonna be
tricky man
what a shame what a shame